Speaker 1: Remember that even in 2022, the David
Pakman show continues to be sponsored primarily
by viewers and listeners through the David Pakman
Show membership program, I invite you to sign up
at Join Packman dot com. You can use the coupon
code. Wow. 22. That's and you have to say it
that way. Wow. Twenty two. All one word. All
lowercase and you will get a discount. That is.
This type of thing, they might outlaw this if,
depending on who wins in November, they may outlaw
this type of discount. Sign up at join Packman
dot com. OK, am I ready to tell you how insane the
US COVID numbers are? No, why not? Well, we
don't have the full numbers from the last
few days because of the New Year's holiday. I
can tell you that the numbers have gone nuclear
or nuclear to quote certain people,
OK, you know, former President Bush,
but we don't yet have the full numbers, but it's
looking like real infections, real because a lot
of people don't test at all or, you know, all
that stuff. We may be talking 1.5 to 1.8 million
COVID infections a day in the U.S., U.S.. OK,
real number. We will get to that. The question
about this insanely transmissible
Micron variant is what will it do
and for how long? In terms of hospitalization
and death, although if it's this contagious,
the total burden on society is going to go up
because it's so contagious, you're still going
to get hospitalizations, you're still going to
get deaths if it is dramatically less deadly
as a percentage of cases of infections. It could
very quickly accelerate our progress to the end
of the pandemic phase, which will just go to the
endemic phase. One place we are looking at very
closely is South Africa, because South Africa
was we don't say it was the place it came from,
but it was one of the earliest countries to be
very open about the data of the number of people
infected, et cetera. We now have news from South
Africa. South Africa says it has passed its fourth
wave of cases, meaning they believe that Omicron
is essentially done or ending in South Africa,
and it counts very few added deaths. Now, if
you're saying but David, a lot of things are
different here. We're going to get to that. We're
going to get to that. New York Times, the South
African government said Thursday. Data suggests
the country has passed its Omicron peak without
a major spike in deaths, offering cautious hope
to other countries grappling with the variant.
Some scientists were quick to
forecast the pattern elsewhere,
so let's look at the numbers that we had. Now,
as you can see, if you're watching, you can see
this massive case spike, I mean, going from about
300 cases a day. To 23000 cases a day. OK, that's
that's almost a, you know, a 200 x increase of
150 or something like that increase in cases. But
their cases are now down something like what's
that? Six over 24, down about 66 percent. But
deaths had a very modest spike. We don't not
care about these deaths, they're still tragic.
But when you see that cases went up, what,
150 to 200 times and deaths went up from about
30 a day to like 60 a day. You say that that's
pretty notable. That's pretty notable now.
Why might it be different in the United States or
in other countries? There's a bunch of different
reasons. First of all. During earlier waves,
South Africa had very low levels of vaccination,
meaning that earlier waves sort of burned through
the population, large parts of the population.
The Bayda variant, which was not huge outside
of South Africa, went through there. That
may provide more sort of population protection to
these are questions. It may remember that Delta
different lineage than Macron, not believed to not
believe to provide significant protection against
Macron on Macron is based on an earlier
lineage. It split earlier, so to speak.
It's theorized that the Bayda variant, having
burned through South Africa might make Omicron
particularly less severe in South Africa, and
we might not have that. We don't have that. And
it may be notable in the United States that the
number one so we have to wait and see. Number two,
the South African population is much younger than
the United States. Five percent of South Africa's
population is 65 plus 16 percent of the U.S.
population is 65 plus. That's a very different.
So if we have to guess right now, there's these
two competing stories. It'll be insanely bad in
the United States, or it'll be just like South
Africa. The most likely scenario based on what
we have now because lower rate of hospitalization
is being observed in a lot of different places,
is that it will be worse in the U.S. than in South
Africa. But it won't be nearly as bad on a on a
case rate basis as earlier waves were. The other
thing that's sort of important to remember is in
the UK, even the rising hospitalization numbers,
a ton of the people hospitalized with COVID
are not hospitalized because of COVID. When
you test everyone who is in the hospital
and you have something so contagious that could be
40 percent asymptomatic, you're going to find tons
of people who have it and are in the hospital for
something else, they still count. So my view here
is still cautious optimism, and we're
going to continue looking at the numbers.